We're going to talk about frogs,
so yeah.
Are you okay?
So yeah,
when we saw,
I mean,
when I saw the video that you put up,
was it two days ago now?
Yeah.
Two days ago.
I couldn't believe it.
Yeah.
And the next morning I got an email from
my brother who also studies symbolism
and it's very,
very smart person.
And he said,
does Jordan know he's incarnating pepe
right now.
Yeah.
Well that's the funny thing is,
you know,
I knew about pappy,
but what it was,
I had nothing like that on my mind when
I made the video.
It never even entered my mind that that
was an association.
I mean I was just concentrating on this
kermit thing that had popped up that
probably popped up about two years ago
and I.
The first time someone said that I
thought,
Huh.
So I went and listened to Kermit and I
thought,
Oh yeah,
I do have a voice that similar to that I
see I can get it lower,
but my voice tends to rise up into my
right,
into my cause of tension.
So.
So this is it.
We need to do like,
so we need to do the metaphysics of
PIPPA.
No one has done it yet,
I think.
Yes,
exactly.
Exactly.
Well,
and so you know,
and then then this strange occurrence.
So of course also also emerged with
regards to the mask that Charles had
made me wear the hat.
Yeah.
Which it looks like Pippi has red lips,
which is staggering.
It's absolutely staggering.
And so I just about fainted when I,
after I posted that and people start,
people pointed out the correspondents
with pepe.
Really?
I just about fainted.
It was.
And that doesn't happen very often.
Like I can only remember one other time
in my life when I was shocked enough to
almost faint.
I just thought that was just too much.
It was too much to bear.
And then thinking about the
correspondence is since then it has
been.
Well it's,
it's,
it's inexplainable and absurd.
But so much of this is inexplicably
Missouri.
I don't know,
I tweeted something yesterday,
uh,
I looked at maps of meaning my book on
the Amazon,
a seller lists to see where it was
located and it was number eight on,
on books that are associated with
behaviorism andw ,
and it was bracketed by two other books,
mastery.
Inbound is cheese book,
and she's the person who invented the
iat that's been used to fair it out.
Unconscious bias.
Oh my goodness.
The other one was a book by Richard
Bandler that I think was called frogs
and princesses just.
And then to find out about cat,
you know,
I didn't know about CAC.
Anyways,
it's.
And then today I was thinking I was
watching Nina Paley who was an absolute
genius and she's animated the plagues
that,
that Moses called down on the Pharaoh.
And of course one of the plagues was a
plague of frogs.
Yeah.
And so,
okay.
And so the,
the,
the frog
is,
is a,
is a perfect liminal character because
the frog,
and I think you tweeted about this as
well,
the frog lives both in water and on
land.
And so it's like a,
it has a monstrous characteristic that
it can cross.
It's one of those things that crosses
over between,
between worlds.
Um,
and so you see that,
you see that in the story.
It's the story of the,
of the frog and the princess is a
perfect example.
And he relates to the Pinocchio story
that we talked about earlier.
Uh,
so,
uh,
princess goes to a pond,
she's playing with her favorite thing,
which is this golden ball.
And so she drops the ball just to
mention something.
That golden ball is the same thing as
the snitch that Harry Potter chases in
the quidditch games and Harry Potter.
And it's funny because inside the snitch
is actually part of Voldemort's soul,
right?
So,
and so that's part of the soul of evil
that's inside the Golden Ball and the
golden bowl.
And Harry Potter has wings,
which makes it around chaos.
Technically speaking.
It's an alchemical symbol.
And the round chaos is a mercurial
symbol.
And the spirit,
mercury is an emissary of the gods.
And so the,
the guards are speaking to you and when
anything flickers in front of you and
captures your attention,
and in the quidditch game,
the person who follows what captures his
attention is the seeker and also the
person who wins.
Not so much the game,
but the metagame.
What's important,
I think in this story,
is that the ball is the most important
thing.
That's why it's golden.
It's golden.
So for her it's the idea that it is the
most important thing.
So she drops this ball in the end,
the water it gets,
it gets lost.
So she loses the most important thing.
It falls into chaos,
right?
So that's the death of God purposes
or,
or just the idea of.
Yeah.
Or just the idea of,
of,
of the loss of innocence or you know,
whatever.
Whatever you think about it in terms of
the loss of the most important thing.
And so this rog appears and says,
you know,
I can go get your ball if you,
if you,
if you promise something for me.
And so the promise is that she will
bring the frog with her into her castle.
Let the frog eat with her and then let
the dog sleep in her bed.
Okay,
so when got those two things,
food and sex we talked about before as
well,
so she saw the frog goes down into the
water and then brings up the most
important thing and the princesses
forced to accept this frog in her.
She doesn't want to be like she's very
annoyed that she has to to to to to let
the frog into her house,
eat from a plate and then finally into
her bed.
But by doing that,
the fraud of course transforms into a
prince.
Here you have this,
this,
this idea that we talked about before
where the most important thing goes out
into chaos and whatever can bring it,
bring it back,
right?
Whatever it can bring it back to us has
can be tamed and can enter into,
into the world.
Can you find this place into the world
maybe even turns into this thing of the
highest value?
Yes,
exactly.
Well,
that's something for people to really
think about.
About,
about marriages for example.
So you know,
people are always,
and I think this is part of the profound
immaturity of our culture.
People are always running around waiting
to find the perfect person who's perfect
for them.
And so you know,
one thing you might think is that if you
ever found the perfect person,
they would run away from you screaming
immediately.
So because and so that perfection is
something that you have to build within
a relationship.
And so you accept the other person,
so to speak,
warts and all and hope that they do the
same to you and swear that you won't run
from each other.
And then as a consequence of that,
you can engage in a mutual process of
transformation that emerges as a
consequence of telling the truth and,
and,
and having a truthful relationship.
And then as a consequence of that,
the transformation can take place and
you might start with a frog,
but maybe you end up with a prince.
So like we talked about the idea that,
that this is the structure of the world.
And so it happens as much on a personal
level as it does on a,
on a social level,
on a bigger,
bigger,
bigger sense.
So just that little hint we talked about
before,
the story of Abraham and the three
angels coming and announcing the birth
of a of Abraham's son.
Well,
in the story of sleeping beauty,
that's exactly what happens.
The queen goes to the pond and there,
Lo and behold,
there's a talking frog and the frog is
the one who announced it to the queen
that she will have a child,
the most beautiful child in the world.
And so again,
here is this idea of something coming
from chaos.
Well that's interesting because you
know,
in the diagrams in my book,
in maps of meaning,
one of the diagrams is an egg shape
that,
that is the chaos into which things
plunge.
But chaos is,
it is an absolute state.
In some sense.
It's,
it's the state of the unknown as such.
And you never see the unknown as such.
You always see something that's partly
known and partly unknown.
And that's what the frog is sitting on
the edge of the pond.
The frog enables you.
So the,
the,
the frog is an emissary of chaos,
roughly speaking.
And you always,
you only meet an emissary of chaos.
You'd never meet chaos because it's,
it's,
it's like,
uh,
um,
it's a non
non non non existent.
It's being,
it's below being,
if you will.
Right?
Right.
Exactly.
And so,
so now this thing like,
well,
two things,
one is interesting is that kermit the
frog is,
is the same thing because kermit is,
is a host,
he's a host on a,
on a show.
And so what he does is he transitions.
He's the transition between different
worlds.
So you have an act and then you have
this transitional figure which appears
and then you have another act.
And so that's what,
that's the role that kermit the frog
plays on the muppet show.
Yes.
Primary problem is ms dot peggy,
who's a really loud feminist.
That's hilarious.
Okay.
And now,
now pepe,
because well here's,
here's,
here's the,
here's the metaphysics of Pippi.
So this is what's happening in the world
right now,
is that there's a very strange situation
where the,
the,
the people like let's say the right,
we'll call them the right or like the
forces of order or the,
the,
the let's say the norm,
the people who create the norm for
society.
Okay.
So we're in a situation where things
have been inverted and the people who
supposedly in the narrative are the ones
who create the norm are,
are,
are being marginalized,
they're being pushed into the,
into the margins,
right?
And to be told you're the ones who
create the norm and we're going to push
you out into,
into the margin.
And so
that's where they've identified with the
frog.
That's why they have identified with the
park.
Because the,
the,
what happens is there's a strange
inversion that happens,
right?
The power of inversion and the power of
mocking.
And the power of,
of humor is usually on the side of,
of cast.
It's usually on this side of the power
of the margin.
Well,
I noticed like I noticed this happening
about 20 years ago is all the,
the right wing had all the comedians.
I thought,
what the Hell's going on here?
The right wing doesn't have the
comedians.
It's the rich.
The left.
It has the comedians.
They're the ones that are poking fun.
So strange that the comedians have
become the,
the right wing has started to express
itself in comedy.
Yeah.
So that,
that,
that is a sign that there's a,
there's this strange inversion that's
happening.
Uh,
and so there's,
there's an interesting,
like just a little footnote on this,
like in the,
in the Bible there's a story that talks
about this.
It's the story of Elijah.
So the time will be Lija.
Israel has been worshiping false gods
because of the Queen Jezza Bell,
right?
And Elijah who is supposed to be the
prophet of the God of that,
of those people has become a marginal
figure.
And so his name is Elijah the stranger,
which is very odd because he's not a,
he is supposed to be a prophet of God
and his tool,
his mockery.
He mocks the prophets of Baal.
And that's something that you actually
don't see very often in the Bible where
the tool to kind of bring back order is
through mockery.
And so this is what we're seeing with
this pip.
A figure is that pep a is like a,
it's like an inversion machine.
Okay.
So,
so,
so the,
the people who use pippy,
what they do is they take something like
an insult that's being thrown at them
and they flip it around,
flip it around on those that insulted
them.
Like that's what you did with the kermit
thing,
which is perfect.
You,
you see people are making fun of you
because they say you sound like kermit
and you're saying,
okay,
I'm going to take this and I'm going to
make it into my strength.
And that's what pip a pip.
It does.
And so a lot of the crazy stuff that's
coming out of this tip,
a thing is,
is,
is part of that.
There's a lot of dark things in,
in the Pipa,
you know,
like things that like personally I
wouldn't want to touch.
When I first saw the frog the frog,
I really recoiled from it.
It's,
it's got this kind of underground comic
horror associated with it that I really,
I really find distasteful.
So like sort of viscerally distasteful.
Yeah,
but I think it's supposed,
it's kind of supposed to do that to you
in that part of the power of,
of those that are using that,
that image,
like it's right there.
If you look at it,
it's right there.
And the first comic,
like the first hippie comic,
you know,
you have a very crass but,
but here's this,
this frog,
right?
Who,
who goes to the toilet to urinate,
but he pulls his pants down to his knees
and so he's doing something that usually
you,
if you pull your pants down to your
knees,
you're going to sit and do something
else.
But then he does that.
But he stands.
And so here's this.
And he shows us his backside,
right?
So here's this,
this strange power of inversion,
which actually brings the man to stand
back up.
And so that's this double inversion that
people who use this,
this,
this type of imagery are doing.
And so even it's like,
you know,
let's say like the radical left wing
saying your,
your,
this,
whatever,
you're a white male controlling
Blahblahblahblahblah,
you're all these things.
And the people who use these pepe comics
there,
they say yes,
and they'll,
and they reflect that to you.
And then the people who were accused
them of that completely lose their mind.
They completely lose their mind.
But the only thing they're doing is
saying,
you're saying,
let's say that I'm a racist,
this blah blah blah.
And then they reflect that back to them.
They invert it in a way because they're
saying,
here you go,
I'll show you what you're telling me I
am.
And then,
and then the,
you know,
the,
the left,
the radical left wing lose their mind.
And so it's like.
And so it's kind of.
And if you look at those people like the
alt right people,
they have this strange,
strange magic,
right?
Because look at,
if you look at Milo is Milo Yiannopoulos
is a perfect example.
You know,
here is a half Greek,
half Jewish,
gay Catholic,
trump supporting enrichment Englishman
in America.
And,
and so not talking to the Republicans.
Exactly.
And so nothing people can throw it in
and we'll stick on him because he is the
frog.
Like he is that marginal figure standing
on the side,
but he's,
he's,
he's like,
he is that double in virgin and he,
he's kind of,
I know if he's trying,
but what it seems like he's doing is
bringing order back through like this
double flip that's happening.
It's very odd.
Very strange.
It's very strange time.
So anyways,
I would just say just just,
I mean,
just be careful.
It's a dangerous place to stand.
Yeah,
I'm,
yes,
I'm trying to be careful.
Believe me,
I've got lots of people that I'm talking
to that are helping me formulate my
arguments and articulate them properly
and like I'm doing my best to keep my
feet on the ground and my eyes open and,
and,
and not to be angry about this,
but to be in the chaos really.
And not assume also that that's a
catastrophe because I don't know what's
going to happen to me.
I don't know if this is the worst thing
that ever happened to me or the best
thing that ever happened to me.
I can't tell.
Yeah.
And what'd you,
what the solution will happen inside the
chaos,
right?
The,
the,
the Jonah gets pulled down by the whale
down into the depths of the,
uh,
of the,
of the ocean and it's while he's in the
belly of the whale,
that the solution comes to him like his
face,
if he,
he has,
he has this moment of repentance where
he turns,
he turns around.
Repentance is a flipping around and so
that the moment that he brings him into
death,
turns into this baptism where he comes
out and he's,
you know,
and he's a,
he's a,
he goes into the city,
right?
So that's another part,
but,
so that,
yeah,
the solution is going to come out of
this chaos right now.
It's still great
problem.
If it's a really complex problem,
you have to go very far into chaos to
find a solution.
But there's always the risk of losing
yourself when you're in chaos.
So that.
Right.
Well,
that's right.
I mean,
that's the thing about dragons is that
they can eat you.
Yeah.
That's why I don't like the new age,
age suffocation of Carl Young,
stinking and in part,
I think Joseph Campbell was responsible
for that,
although he did a lot of very good
things.
I mean,
the thing about the thing about
confronting the thing that you're afraid
of is that the thing that you're afraid
of is genuinely terrifying and it can
actually eat you and it's eaten plenty
of people before you.
And so it's no joke and you know what I
mean?
During this whole,
let's call it ride so far.
I mean,
what,
yeah,
what was going to happen,
and especially in the first couple of
weeks,
I mean,
when I was being called a bigot,
transphobic,
all of those things and being pilloried
essentially,
at least within the university for my
views,
um,
it wasn't obvious at all that there was
going to be any,
uh,
there was going to be any way of
swimming out of it,
let's say.
So,
but it's uh,
it's,
it's very,
it's very disturbing because now you
have,
you basically have these two monsters
fighting each other,
you know,
like that you have,
let's say this pepe type frog and you
know,
the Hippie was declared a hate,
uh,
hate symbol by the Anti Defamation
League.
You know,
that.
I mean,
that's very frightening.
It's frightening that this is how far
it's gone,
how much.
It's like,
you know,
all of a sudden they see that they can
see the monster on the other side,
but they don't see the monster on their
side,
you know,
and,
and the,
the LGBTQ,
etc.
Etc.
I mEan,
that is itself a,
a liminal forum.
Look
what's happening with it.
It's the same thing that,
that happened with the gender neutral
pronouns.
As soon as you blew the binary apart,
there was an endless multiplication of
potential identities.
Now was the chaos manifesting itself and
the ever expanding letters that go along
with lbgt is an example of exactly the
same thing.
It's like,
well,
we're marginalized.
Well,
we're marginalized too.
And how about us were also marginalized
and it's like,
and I guess that's also partly because
each person has at least one element of
that seriously marginalized,
marginalized in some manner.
Yeah.
And the rain.
and it's interesting like the rainbow is
a,
is actually a perfect symbol because a
rainbow is,
is,
is actually,
uh,
is just a,
it's,
it's a fluid thing.
It is a fluid thing or rambo is not six
colors or rainbow is a spectrum of
colors and there's,
there's,
it is chaos itself.
It's the division of order into an
indefinite amount of things.
Right?
So we,
we,
we typify a rainbow into six coLors but,
but it's actually just the spectrum of.
And so it is in definitively,
it can be separated indefinitely,
right?
It's no limit to how much it can be.
It seems to me that that's actually the
problem with the identity legislation.
It's like,
well,
like marriage,
isn't that like an identity is a very
important thing,
right?
And identity is something you have,
but it's also something that you and I
play out.
So you have to negotiate your identity
with the rest of the social world.
It's like a game in some sense,
but identity also has to have a function
like,
and this is also why the legislation is
so pernicious because it just says,
well your identity is whatever you want
it to be.
And it's like,
well no,
it's not because you have to live with
other people.
It's like,
it's like saying you can play whatever
game you want to play.
it's like,
well you can't because you got to get
people to play with.
That's right.
We were playIng together and you can
say,
well you have to play my game.
Well I can tell you toddlers on the,
on the school ground who say you have to
play my game.
They just get shunned and then the game
itself has to be playable.
That's the other thing is that there,
there,
there are playable and non playable
games and one of the things that piaget
pointed out,
the developmental psychologist piaget
pointed out about a game is that one of
the hallmarks of an acceptable game is
that people want to play it voluntarily.
And that's another part of the
legislation that's so pernicious.
It's like,
okay,
you have a game and it's a game that
you've chosen subjectively,
because that's what it says in the
legislation and when,
when you come near me,
you have to play my game whether you
want to or not.
And then the problem with that too is
that,
well where does that stop?
And the answer is it stops with
indefinite multiplication.
So the whole point of society is to
enforce a game that somewhat arbitrary
that everyone can more or less play.
They sacrifice parts of themselves to
play it,
but it it,
it beats the total chaos of,
of,
of the war against,
of all,
against all.
For example,
that's the hobbs zen right nightmare,
right?
And life is nasty,
brutish and short.
This is A compliment to the discussion
of the metaphysics of pepe.
The frog that I had with Dr.
Jordan Peterson.
There are strains,
transformations happening our world,
and hopefully understanding them will
prevent the worst from taking shape.
As I discussed with Dr.
Peterson,
the frog is a type of hybridity as an
amphibian.
It exists in two worlds.
At the same time,
so it becomes an image of the margin.
Another possible aspect of the margin
and the monster as we encounter it,
is to be a shapeshifter shapeshift
shifting like hybridity is the sign of
the place where categories fall apart on
the edge.
In the case of shape shifting.
This characteristic because presented
mostly as a power of the margin,
is the power of fluidity like a
trickster,
taking on several forms to operate his
mischief.
To fully understand how pepe the frog
operates,
we need to understand how shape shifting
occurs and how it gives power to those
who wield it.
You see,
pepe has become a meme,
possibly the most used meme of all
times,
his images floating on the internet and
it can be produced by anyone in the
world,
and so there are thousands and thousands
of images of pepe ranging from a
glorified emoji to the most horrifying
scatological images you can imagine
because pepe has become this chaotic,
fluid shape shifting thing.
He ends up acting like a mirror in the
same way water acts as a mirror,
and the way that works is that because
there are so many images of pepe,
when people look into that huge chaos of
images,
they can't encompass it,
all of it.
They have to mentally order it and in
ordering it they do that using their own
mental patterns,
but as they project their thinking into
this chaos and as they forced the chaos
to take shape becomes an image of their
own ideas,
maybe their own ideological possession,
and so one of the things that has been
happening is that some people on the
right what,
what some groups are calling the alt
righter or whatever have been using this
effect to act as a mirror against the
social justice warrior types and even
went so far that the sjws finally
declared pip a hate symbol.
The aNti defamation league said that
pepe was a hate symbol.
I mean this frog,
this cartoon frog.
It was so ridiculous that the adl
finally scaled back.
Some of the language they use.
I mean,
of course it was politically motivated,
but how could such a silly thing happen?
Well,
certain images of pepe,
a few of them in the thousands,
thousands of images available had racist
themes and so there was a hitler pepe
and a k,
k,
k dot pepe,
scheming jus african stereotyped using
racist slurs,
cliche mexicans.
All of these examples were floating with
the other thousands and thousands of
peppa images online,
but when the social justice warriors
looked in this mirror,
this pond of pepe images,
all they could see were the ones that
reflected back to them their own
ideology or rather like a mirror,
an inversion,
the dark shadow of their ideology.
Of course,
immediately the accusation came that bay
is a racist symbol.
He's a hate image and the irony is very
big because first of all,
no one controls this image.
No one has any control over it.
Pepe is everything and anything and
nothing at the same time by declaring
publicly that he's a hate symbol.
That's two are pointing to their own
absurdity and this to the delight of
those that use this image,
but heidi in this is an even larger ird.
If you look at the images that they
pulled out as being racist images.
There's this strange contradiction in
though.
You see on one side there is hitler pepe
and kkk pepe,
and there's a trump pepe.
Well,
on the other side,
there's the scheming jew,
the african american,
and the mexican.
This means that pepe is that the same
time the archetipal oppressor seemed
from the side of the victim,
all the while being the archetypical
scapegoat seen from the side of the
oppressor,
that it's pepe is both sides of racism.
At the same time,
when the sjws look at that automatically
without even thinking,
they organize it through the ideology
and it exposes their program because the
automatically decide that when pepe is
hitler or kick a care,
trump pipa is identifying with those
people,
but when he's a scheming jew or a
mexican,
pipa is mocking and criticizing those
people.
Why is such an absurd image of hitler as
a cartoon frog not seen as mocking
hitler,
in fact,
all the stw users seeing is a reflection
of themselves,
of their nightmare,
of their shadow.
The rather pathological desire we've
seen in the past few months to accuse
everyone being hitler or a neo nazi or a
white nationalist is an expression of
their secret desire,
the desire to be confirmed through an
encounter with their projected other,
and it's funny because the discourse of
otherness has been an ideological tool
of the left since the 19 sixties and now
we're at a time when it has come back to
haunt them.
So by using this strategy,
the people have been wielding this
pepper image have taken advantage of the
power of chaos,
taken advantage of what happens when the
frog jumps into the pond and goes down
to the bottom to find the golden ball.
As I explained in my interview with Dr.
Peterson about the story of the princess
and the frog,
but the frog can't stay in the water
forever.
That's the most important thing.
At some point you have to finish the
story
to finish the story of the frog has to
get the golden ball and one could say
that the golden ball is actually the sun
which will come up for the new day.
The frog has to get the golden ball and
bring it back to the surface of the
water.
It must carry the most important thing,
carry the seed of the new world to the
princess so that it can grow.
If that doesn't happen,
there is no telling what else can come
out of the water.
If the frog stays there for too long,
it will be eaten or it will call some
dark or monster because there are other
things down there beside the golden ball
and the frog contempt,
the leviathan to devour it,
and it's not as if this is impossible.
As the frog swims in the darkness,
the social justice warriors still
peering into the mirror and calling
forth its shadow.
You've already seen some intimations
that this game,
people are playing my race,
something more than a new day.
Mike,
raise the very monster,
the social justice warriors hope to
encounter so as the frog swims in the
water.
How?
How can it do that?
How can it recognize the golden ball
that is at the bottom of the pond
because it's actually not easy to
distinguish things when we're covered in
darkness
and the answer to this is in what
happens in the story.
The frog has to get out of the water and
become a prince.
The frog has to become something else
and bringing up the golden ball is the
same thing as the transformation of the
frog into a prince.
One cannot happen without the other,
and so as Dr.
Peterson is often suggested in his
lectures,
the way to do it is to sort ourselves
out,
is to go into our own self,
define the golden ball that is hidden in
the darkness,
to go down and find the most important
thing of western civilization.
And Dr.
Peterson has suggested the most
important thing of western civilization
is the logos.
This truth,
that is the Word we have seen.
How noise has been the chaos used to
drown the word.
What I'm going to talk about,
what is freedom of speech?
I want to tell you a few things about
taking off this very carefully.
I've been thinking about this very
carefully over the last two weeks
because of the videos,
and so we must find the word for it is
the sun that rises after darkness.
The word is the thing that comes out of
death and lives again.